ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata adesso
tantissime volte ci chiedete qual è il
segreto delle nostre ricette perché
quello che facciamo
all'interno di questa cucina di mio
cugino cugino si è anche di roberta da
oggi sola persona di meglio il cugino
piuttosto che la guberti come mai quello
che facciamo qui dentro a una marcia a
quel sapore che nessun altro sa è
semplice perché all'interno di ogni
piatto dall'inizio di questa rubrica
quattro mesi fa fino ad oggi ci sono
sempre i germi di mio fratello fatto e
noi vogliamo dire basta al colpo di
tosse che ogni volta sentiamo
all'interno di questa cucina e che ci ha
rotto
ecco perché con l'avvento del cambio
stagione abbiamo pensato di fare un
qualcosa di nuovo
ossia rubare come sempre nella ricetta
che ho fatto qualcun altro perché noi
crearne manco morto per produrre un
rimedio naturale contro l'influenza la
tosse io per i rimedi naturali non è che
sia proprio di base non mi curo e
aspetto che la morte arrivi però perché
non tentare questa ricetta e soprattutto
quanto è bello avere una curcuma con
ancora dei confetti attaccati come
bomboniera del matrimonio di chi è di
mia madre del matrimonio di mia madre
chissà quale di ricevuto questo il
cattivo gusto
che dire partiamo quindi con gli
ingredienti tra parentesi ringraziamo
gabry ponte come si chiama gabry auguri
tiano gabry ponte non è tipo delle
streghe vinci dice innanzitutto degli
ingredienti saranno curcuma la radice di
zenzero fresca da manca una quanto è è
che c'era quella radice di zenzero
questa cosa utilizzati per il presepe
l'anno prossimo di valenti peperoncino
macinato 1 girone miele
ora che il pepe nero non c'è il muro
mentre il vennero fa male piccolo sta
bene
no il pepe nero non fa bene per quanto
io lo adori gabry per favore lo facciamo
scherzetti partiamo subito con la
preparazione
prendiamo una ciotola un bicchiere
prendiamo innanzitutto un bicchiere per
prima cosa aggiungiamo un cucchiaio di
curcuma quali sono le proprietà della
curcuma anticancerogena francia migliore
antitumorale ma non solo quello è una
spezia con un motto del board della boe
il parere del medico era piatta
antiossidante antiossidante anti
infiammatore e antinfiammatoria poi
sull'azione depurativa eco la cosa cosa
casa depurativa con la coca cola ghoga
scusate qualche medico con la gorga e
una parola in italiano un po di problemi
con la droga
quello e aggiunge un cucchiaio e di
zenzero noci nato nel frattempo dichiato
gianmarco a questo punto le proprietà
dello zenzero mamma proprio il medico è
la curcuma
ottime proprietà lo zenzero pazzesco
casinò sono al meglio con un nativo
contro navi e invenzioni di a marchio ce
ma non di metterlo amplificati vendola
degli animali neffa dolori mestruali e
problemi la digestione favorisce anche
se il mio foniatra mi ha detto che con
lo zenzero non il mio foniatra tipo con
la gorga troppo zenzero però rischia di
irritare e di creare anzi reflusso
gastrico e arriva del sistema
immunitario che è perfetto per questa
stagione direi no lo zero ma altre
proprietà e anche antitumorali la prima
al comparto del turismo e favorisce la
distensione muscolare
oddio gente cioè se tu hai il
raffreddore tu prendi questo qui e
dipinge una parete di muco a ritenere
serbi che bello è bello divertirsi però
perché non provare anche a fare qualcosa
di utile per concluderla ok come fatto
come facciamo un cucchiaio e mezzo di
miele te ne prego mia casa la prima di
sapere fa benissimo il trattamento della
diarrea o per terry tirati contro l'asti
xvi sai cos'è la stipsi certo l'opposta
la diarrea stipsi ha quindi tipo i tassi
questo autunno che ci verso l'olio
disegnino lo ha portato james antenne il
primo nutrimento daniele di palach
leader api che viveva a zurigo
[Applauso]
ringraziamo pana grid e le diciamo che
noi non siamo solamente ottima cucina ma
siamo anche cultura possiamo dirlo
in questo momento un pizzico di
peperoncino come poi procedere b e
mettere un pizzico giusto non certo per
la pressione non è un regolatore della
pressione insieme all'aglio le sete
magni dato che mette ko lo mette ko gli
altri la circolazione sanguigna andrà a
stare insorgere di battere ma se il
colesterolo laburismo padre santa
ragazzi anti battello antistaminico
davvero il pepe nero è vero fino a un
alleato della salute un alleato della
salute stimolare nella bolina e
favorisce la digestione e poi il succo
di 1 tito con ea io intanto giro non ho
né base messo insieme nello bicester
limone fa è vicina antisettico e ampi
tossico un bicchiere di salute quindi
possiamo dire che all'interno di questo
coso ci stanno tutte le fanno benissimo
ed e cura figura quel si esiga consta
questa cosa per santa
l'appello è un concentrato di zeus
stesso non è che tu fai questa roba qui
e te la devi finire tutta quanta lo
sciroppo della corsa del telos coli
mattina a pranzo e cena per rovinarti
tutti e tre i pasti secondo me tra
parentesi all'interno del video dice una
influenza in un giorno molto corta
accada questo
oddio ragazzi vomito
no non hanno infuso così ci vuole un
altro po di niente perché tu sue più
denso dal più schifiltoso all'ultimo
quindi enrico attento a te il primo
cucchiaio che se poi un altro cibo già
le labbra to presero enrico danni da
anni ma siete tutti i malati ma che è
lazzaretto vieni arriva beh sì ben riso
buono ma chissà di zenzero curcuma il
sentito iele non sento peperoncino bene
no perché adesso l'ho rimesso qua dentro
non sento il limone io sto pure bene
vorrei dire da sole alcun poco chiara
quella che fa un malato lui appelli e
lasciamo solo quando ne facciamo
qualcosa di buono mio cugino non vede
niente quando c'è qualcosa di orribile
il suo frigo e pieno di boe qualora
volessi pochino di sciroppo per la tosse
t a cupido è
e tu non senti limone tu non hai la
lingua si affacciavano il nostro cucina
è tentata di oggi no un cucchiaio giulia
malvagio ma tu non lo senti riponendo
devo dire questo qui è ottimo perché ti
fa vomitare l'influenza mai però ben
bene cosa sia troppo allora ragazzi
purtroppo la videocamera si è spenta
proprio quando assaggiato gianmarco
quindi sarei l'unico che sta bene e che
prenderà due volte devo fà anche le
stesse battute di prima no no e essere
onesto di love
qual è il tuo parere onesto che è
discreto vale la pena se state male vale
la pena poi c'è salti timone tanto molto
di limone gianmarco e non è capace di
ripartire
simone santi timone tanto sa molto di
limone e alla fine ma le molte persone
non sentono i sapori quando sono
influenzate questa è nuova a me ne vado
così siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata io vi faccio solamente una
richiesta se vi va state male di fare da
cavie per favore e mi fate sapere se
effettivamente questo miscuglio ha
funzionato in qualche modo perché io ho
dei dubbi per quanto possono essere
benefiche e pazzesche le proprietà della
roba che ci abbiamo messo le paga temi
su instagram oppure semplicemente
il momento qua sotto chiedo scusa a
tutti quanti medici tre volte nel giorno
guarda che si perché di 25 milioni
tuscanese noi ci vediamo la prossima
domenica è sempre un'altra puntata di
cucina abbuffata e presenterebbe su sky
cambi la lingua colpo dopo diventa
un'altra cosa ho fatto questo che dire
si dava la prossima settimana e vabbè
essere mi dà niente e dico tu secondo me
qualcosa e psicologico questo coso il
prodotto il tarlo nel cervello
e così a chiudiamo ciao ragazzi già
buttata